[Music]
so monar the legacy of Monsters has at
all its episodes it was a beauty of a
show no doubt although with quite a few
inconsistencies that we will address in
another video up next this summer we
will be seeing another Monster Series in
the form of House of the Dragon
featuring The Waring tar Arians and
their Fantasy Dragons the biggest of
them all is vagar completely dwarfing
the other dragons like GIS melees and
even the biggest one from the Game of
Thrones drogon who is nowhere near in
comparison in size and Majesty here in
this video though we will do a crossover
comparison between the targaryan dragon
vagar and the Iron Dragon from the
recent Monarch series and showcase which
one is bigger and which one is more
deadly in a fight so let's get to it to
get this started we will first have to
estimate the size of vagar and get to
the bottom of it all this green dragon
was one of the original dragons of the
late agon the Conqueror who had in his
command three including her the other
two being the larger Bion and mirais
although at the start of the show House
of the Dragon valerion had already died
of old age living up to two centuries
and marxis had been killed by the daish
forces during that Conquest B in the
black dread was stated to be so large
that the shadow of its wingspan covered
entire towns and cities and by the time
of the dance of the Dragons vagar had
reached a size that rivaled the black
dragon of aegon although still being a
bit smaller and less robust than it
anyway let's do the size estimate of
this largest remaining dragon from that
show vegar was stated by the VFX artist
of the show House of the Dragon to be
150 M long which translates to around
were almost 500 ft from snout to the end
of the tail it had a serpentine body
like all the other dragons and was
covered with reptilian scales its
primary color was green with highlights
and hints of yellow and bronze so with
this length it would even be longer than
the monsterverse Godzilla's height which
seems to be quite off as compared to how
it was shown in the series but hey if
they say it was that then who are we to
complain with a 500 ft length or 150 M
its wingspan would definitely be around
900 to 1,000 ft or 270 to 300 M across
that means its wingspan is wider than
even that of Morra and Rodan from the
king of the monsters movie but lesser
than gidora as we can see in the image
it would be way too big as it was stated
in the show a Titan size even compared
to
Godzilla so yeah let's complain we are
still going to do our own reasonable
estimates to its actual size as seen in
the show so as per the episode where Aon
Targaryen to control or Bond it with the
giant green reptile the young Targaryen
was seen to be next to vagar head and it
seems to be around 20 to 25 ft long or 6
to 7.5 M and if we take that head size
and extrapolate the body length given
that it is Serpentine in nature we get a
beast that is around 80 M or more than
260 ft long which seems to be more
reasonable that means that its wingspan
would be in the range of 150 M or around
500 ft meaning that the wingspan was
actually as wide as the official stated
length of the dragon and in the image it
seems to look to be the size of a large
skull Devil with wings and a properly
sized as we can see with Godzilla in the
background so now let's go through the
monsterverse that Titan the Iron Dragon
so when it was first seen in the
Philippines in 1952 in that show it
wasn't really as large as a monsterverse
Titan would have been it looked to be
around 30 to 40 ft or 9 to 12 m in
height and it had a wingspan of over 150
to 200 ft or 45 to 60 M wide so that
would make its body length around 100 ft
or 30 m well roughly but in the end of
the first season it was seen to be
gigantic a real Titan siiz creature an
adult meaning that the earlier one was a
juvenile so this one would be around the
same size as the male mut of
2014 capable of even battling Godzilla
elbe it for just a while but
nevertheless it was seen to have a
wingspan of over 500 to 600 ft wide or
more than 150 to 180 M this was clear
when Godzilla in the end of the fight
was holding one of the wings of the Iron
Dragon and that single wing seems to be
more than half the height of the Gman so
given that Goji is almost 400 ft tall or
120 M that would put the single wing
around 250 to 300 ft and so by simple
mathematics that means a 500 to 600 ft
wide
wingspan so now now let's do our
comparison firstly the Iron Dragon as a
juvenile would be around the same size
as drogon was in Game of Thrones shorter
in length although a bit taller due to
its longer legs and posture its head is
also larger than the serpentine dragons
of the same size from Game of Thrones
now the Iron Dragon as an adult
completely dwarves out drogon and the
other dragons like Caris and melees it
no doubt would have stood around or more
than 100 ft or 30 m tall and would have
a body length of 250 to 300 ft long long
and have a wingspan that is close to or
more than 600 ft or 182 M compared to
our estimate of Vega these two dragons
would be really close in size with the
Iron Dragon still being 40 to 50 ft
longer double in height and also having
a way larger head which would make it
more deadly in melee combat and lastly
its wingspan would be around 30 m or 100
ft wider than that of our estimate of
vagar now what about the officially
stated size of Vega to repeat here Vega
was set to be around 150 M or almost 500
ft long she would therefore stand around
100 ft or 30 m in height which is short
due to its Serpentine design and shorter
legs she would also have a massive wing
span of around 900 to 1,000 ft or 270 to
300 M wide this Dragon would outsize the
Monarch series Iron Dragon by a lot she
would be the same height but more than
200 ft or 60 M longer and then with a
bigger wingspan that is nearly double in
width seeing this Dragon even with
Godzilla near it would give any
monsterverse fans Goosebumps and chills
in the spine so with size out of the way
which one of these is Delia in a fight
to the death if we compare the juvenile
iron dragon against our vagar meaning
vagar as per our size estimate and the
juvenile smaller Iron Dragon from 1952
the result would be highly in favor of
the green dragon the bigger green dragon
from the targarian series although the
Iron Dragon could still be faster and
also with Talons and Claws that can
scrape through metal through a ship
meaning Vega's only Advantage is her
fire breath but in any case she would
still either be greatly injured herself
or she would also die in battle probably
in a crash landing like she would die in
the series and books okay so comparing
our vagar against the adult Iron Dragon
well this is a bit nonsensical the Iron
Dragon would tear the targaryan dragon
to shreds but how would it Faire against
the largest size official version
personally I think that it would come to
a melee fight and which dragon is more
durable and have more resilience and
stamina see vagar is old and her wings
are tatted with torn pieces in the wing
membranes she could fly but her speed
isn't as fast as the younger dragons and
she was stated to have died in a battle
against a smaller caraxes both dying in
a crash the Iron Dragon however as was
seen in the series was fast and Nimble
even for its big size it can also
secrete a sticky substance which can
immobilize lesser creatures it was also
able to fly again immediately after
being thrown against a mountain of the
crash landing hard on its slopes so it
would have higher durability greater
stamina and a more ferocious attack
speed and to top it all it was able to
withstand the atomic breath of Godzilla
meaning that the dragon's fire breath
wouldn't do jack thus even if vegar
was bigger the Iron Dragon would still
win in a fight this might change if
maybe it went up against ban the black
dread maybe now we have come to the end
of the video If you like this one then
watch this other one as well and do
check out our channel for more Monster
and other movie Monsters content well
like subscribe and we'll see you in the
next video take care fam